I'm good thank you thank you so much
I couldn't be that producer I would have
an attitude why are you over here
playing with this man Carmella
[Music]
tyrae gets up and walks out after just
hearing the voice of the guy who
allegedly has been catfishing him as
Carmella it's all right to not be okay
[Music]
but before he made that exit he revealed
an experience he had with Carmella that
is so bad I don't understand how he let
her come back after it I went to
Barbados and then she she never showed
up
who is to blame at this point let's get
into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's Malicia this
week I'm only going to dive into
Tyrese's storyline because I'm really
interested in hearing your thoughts on
his situation after this episode but
just so you're in the loop Amanda and
Rosman finally met in person after four
months of dating online and their first
night together was awkward
understandably it's Amanda's first time
being with another man since her husband
passed away not too long ago overall it
was extremely uncomfortable to watch to
be honest
[Music]
Roswell and I 100 will not have sex
tonight because I do also feel guilty
for even being in a relationship with
Rosman you know because of Jason I think
I'll get over it over time but I mean
that guilt is still there and I'm not
sure if this is the best thing but I
would respect rosvin so much if he chose
to gently step away from this
relationship because she's clearly not
ready and I don't think he's interested
in being a dad also Gino and Jasmine
reunite in Panama and after they hug it
out she gives him the biggest kiss he's
probably had in his entire life
[Music]
thank you
oh baby dang
all right let's move on to Tyree who is
in need of some extra love right now he
has been having a hard time accepting
that he's been catfished by Carmella
the person you've been messaging with
is a man named Christian
the episode starts off with the
producers telling tyrae they have a
recording of the man who has been
playing him for the last four years and
they have a message from him saying how
he feels about what he's done but to my
surprise tyrae doesn't want to hear or
see any of it I don't think I can do it
right now
I'm thinking he's afraid of the feelings
he's going to feel once that
disappointment settles in he's gone
through a lot recently with his mom
having a stroke and him having to take
care of her in their one bedroom
apartment I put myself on the back
burner a lot and I feel like I can
finally look at myself to say you know
it's time for you
my time finally I feel like Carmella has
been his hope throughout the darkness
and to find out what's been keeping you
going it's all an illusion
that's tough
he might be wondering what's going to
keep him going now
what are you doing how do you think he's
doing producer he's sad
it's embarrassing like you guys
Tyree goes on to admit his fault in all
of this that's why I'm just kind of
kind of like like mainly shocked and
like disappointed in myself I know about
computers like I watched the show
Catfish like I know like usually what to
look for when you see a fake profile
like I should have seen it it was like
only Snapchat
yeah
but even after he shares that
Harry still hopes Carmella is real
a misunderstanding
I'm just having trouble processing
everything just because of you know the
amount of time we spent together in you
know the conversations we had the bond
and the love that me and Carmella had
for each other I don't know if he's
getting caught up in the lust Factor
considering he has an experienced sex
yet it's really embarrassing to admit
I'm like 33 years old and still a virgin
or if he thinks the bare minimum of
Snapchat conversations is what he
deserves and without me even knowing him
I can say it's absolutely not initially
asked me for money back in 2019 and I
said no I mean she just kind of was like
okay and kind of ignore me tyrae goes on
to reveal some other major red flags
that popped up during his relationship
with Carmella one is that she would
always ask for money obviously duh I
knew that too and not just that but
she'll get an attitude when he says no
March 2020 she messaged me that's when I
kind of like let my guard down and send
her something look at this text thread
which by the way I always wonder if
these are the exact text messages
for now we'll assume that they are
tyrae says good morning my beautiful
queen and she basically says
where the money at and he says he's kind
of broke right now which by the way I've
always been taught never say you're
broke a better alternative
it's not in my budget it's just not in
my budget right now all right anyway
tyrae says he's broke and Carmela says
you said next week
girl man whoever you are to know that
somebody might not have it and you still
press them for the money as if you're
willing to take their last dime it's
dead wrong and selfish and I'll be
surprised if you ever end up with
lasting Financial comfortability because
of the way you treat people I think
between 50 to 100 a month
you know she doesn't really question
their mind I give her but she just like
is always asking for more Tyree says he
assumed Carmella wasn't scamming him
because he wasn't sending a lot of money
but that's also assuming Carmelo wasn't
talking to anybody else
I'm sure the catfish has a roster
multiple streams of income now the whole
sending money factor wasn't a shocker
for me but this next Revelation had me
thinking now Tyree
it was hard for me to understand the
situation before but now it is beyond me
what's the coolest spot it is it goes
down the next day when tyrae meets up
with his brother and sister to tell them
what's been going on remember no one in
his family knows about Carmella he's
been keeping this relationship to
himself the entire time I didn't tell my
family about Carmella because I keep
things pretty private ever since I was
little and my dad passed away I've
always kept my emotions inside wow
wants us so
so that's draining I hope one day he
feels safe enough to process those
emotions and release them that's a ton
of energy he's using to keep those walls
up when he could be using that energy
towards something more constructive you
know they say the decisions you make in
pain are not wise decisions maybe all of
the things that tyrae is holding in are
clouding his judgment
I try to be the man of the family and
not burden you know my family with any
of my problems but I feel like what's
going on with Carmella is too much to
handle alone so I feel like I need to
open up and let them know what's going
on oh his sister is so pretty if I
didn't brush your hair I did
I picked it out I'm just kidding that's
her letting us know that she notices it
too
you gotta love family
okay with the stuff you got us into
our brother Terry Texas he had something
to tell us which was kind of surprising
to me
my brother's a good person he has a big
heart but we worry about him because he
holds everything in
it's like he never lets anybody know
what's going on in his life at all so
him trying to open up is strange yeah
Tyrese starts to tell them he's been in
an international relationship for four
years I would have never known but then
he drops this tidbit and I'm not gonna
lie I felt some type of way because I'm
like Tyree you aren't going to tell us
this when we first met you
where is she from like you know when I
went to Barbados last year
y'all he don't went to Barbados to try
to meet up with the girl and she didn't
show up now of course we know why
Carmelo and I were dating for three
years before I decided to go to Barbados
like I was super excited to see her
you know I was going to finally meet her
the love of my life imagine turning on
90 day and seeing your picture
and then hearing somebody say they are
in love with you or someone who they
think is you
who is this woman in the pictures I
would love to know how she feels about
all of this so I made some Barbados
I booked my trip for five days Barbados
had very strict covet rules so I had to
actually quarantine for three days so
after I got my native test results I
text her you know when can we meet but
she didn't respond damn she kind of just
ghosted me
he wasted hard-earned money because I
know there is no way he allowed himself
to enjoy Barbados after that and really
the scammer potentially took money out
of his own pocket by having tyrae book a
flight and a hotel knowing no one was
going to show up
you flew there that she couldn't come
out to her own Hometown or home City
whatever it is country to come see you
she said it was because of Kobe as Ty
Rey continues to reveal more about his
relationship with Carmella over the
years you start to see there's a pattern
a lack of acceptance for what's being
obviously shown to him things have been
made clear as day to him multiple times
but he just kept seeing what he wanted
to see walking straight past the red
flags and when you keep doing that who
else can you blame
at the end of the day we are all in
charge of protecting our own hearts
but
at the same time I feel for him I've
never walked a mile in his shoes so I
can't fully understand his decisions
what is obvious is that he's been
hurting and he was vulnerable and
someone took advantage of that yesterday
uh the producers told me that it wasn't
really her I was talking to
it was actually a man that was
pretending to be Carmella huh
yeah
oh wow that is sick very whoever is on
the other side of that little app how do
you even sleep at night
I know and I don't know what to do now
it's like I just don't know what to do
next
and this is this is shocking this is
a surprise yeah he said I'm appalled
I feel bad because you don't just
catfish a person like tyrae because he
is a good-hearted person
my heart is broke for him
[Music]
that's wild
wait how did they confess what'd they
say have like a recording or something
they wanted to play but I didn't want to
hear it right now
I think I should hear it me too girl
you have to know what's going on so you
have some closure
we are right here to support you
Ty Ray finally agrees to listen to the
tape come on oh man
I'm serious I don't know I'm scared
you'll be all right
and I must say I'm glad tyrae chose to
use his resources AKA his brother and
his sister during this difficult time
instead of choosing to struggle in
isolation that's one of the worst and
hardest things you can put yourself
through to try to sit there and battle
your own mind and your emotions by
yourself the whole Man Too
all right
this is a recording of a conversation
one of our producers had with Christian
after we first made contact
are you welcome
so it's okay
uh I'm Christian Christian okay think
about it y'all he's probably also
reeling with the fact that he was sexing
with this man we do have you know
naughty Snapchat sessions
oh that's a lot
that's a lot it's okay
are you okay yeah it's all right to not
be okay
[Music]
hug him tight and don't let him go
he's a love hug he needs to just lay on
someone's chest and weep let it all out
you know tyrae was talking about how
he's always seen himself as the man of
the house and we know that story it's
the need to be strong all the time
but we all have weak moments we're human
we have relationships to support us
during the good times and the bad times
if you're struggling don't be
embarrassed or ashamed to reach out for
support if you reach out to the right
person you will not be a burden to them
at all none of us were built to do this
alone alright next week it looks like
Tyrese's sister is going to start doing
her own investigation do you still in
the back of your mind think that she is
real
a little bit is he serious there is
someone behind these messages that I
have a deep connection with maybe you
know what the producer was told was
wasn't true Did you ever reverse search
the pictures that she sent you no I've
never done that let me try this one see
what comes up
got it
face the truth tyrae and accept it
all right 90 day fans fam thanks for
spending time with me make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next time
[Music]